The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, I guess
we'll get started.
So last time we talked about
hearing loss, and deafness,
and cochlear implants.
Any questions?
So did anyone read the Sunday
New York Times yesterday?
My email really lit up when this
front page article showed up
and it was titled, "Ground
Shaking Noise Rocks NFL
and Eardrums Take a Big Hit."
So the reason my email lit
up is because my lab director
is quoted.
So it's a big deal to be quoted
in the Sunday Times, right?
So this is talking
about the NFL games
where they have a noise
meter down on the field
and they encourage the fans
to make a lot of noise.
And apparently at the Seattle
Seahawks recent game--
whatever-- the
crowd was recorded
at making 136 decibel
noise in September.
And so it says later on in
the article, "Fans accustomed
to hollering may--" is that what
they do at the Seahawks games?
"May scoff at the warnings
as nanny state silliness.
But to auditory experts,
the danger is very real.
People think it's cool
or funny, or whatever.
But there is increasing--"
this is a quote "Increasing
evidence that if your ears are
ringing, damage is happening,
said M. Charles Liberman, a
professor of otology at Harvard
Medical School, and the director
of a hearing research lab
at the Massachusetts
Eye And Ear Infirmary."
So he's a director
of the lab where
we're going to have
a lab tour later.
"There's something
irreversible going on,
and it's only going to get
worse as you get older.
Liberman's research shows that
even in the immediate effects
of noise exposure after the
immediate effects subside--
the ringing, the muffling,
the feeling of pressure-- ears
do not really recover."
So noise damage in the news.
I'll pass it around.
All right.
So yeah, question?
AUDIENCE: I just have
a quick question.
So when I'm down at the
T, it's extremely loud.
Do you happen to know how
loud that is in decibels?
PROFESSOR: I've never
measured it on the T.
AUDIENCE: I had a
friend who tried.
And the thing on his phone
wouldn't go high enough.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
And a lot of folks have
a sound level meter app.
So how high was the maximum?
AUDIENCE: The max was 100,
and it more than maxed out.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Well, so I wouldn't be
surprised if it's 110 dB
on the T. Certain
in between stops
runs are louder than others
as you know if you ride the T.
So I think that
that's not so damaging
that it would hurt your hearing.
But if you were the conductor
or the driver on the train,
you really have
to worry about it.
On the other hand,
if you're the driver,
you have to have good
hearing to respond
to some kind of signals.
So it's not like they can
just wear hearing protection.
In this article
about NFL fans, they
said in some games they hand
out those little foam ear
plugs, which attenuate the
noise as much as 20 dB.
So if you're listening to 120,
put the noise-- ear plug in
and it goes down to 100.
But it also said that some
people, like children,
can't fit the foam ear
plugs in their ear canal.
So it doesn't work for them.
And some people, like
people who work on the T,
need good hearing.
So today, we're going
to move on and get back
to the auditory brainstem.
We had talked about the
auditory pathway that comes up
from the cochlea through
the auditory nerve
and into the cochlear
nucleus, which
is the very lowest
level of the brainstem.
And now we're going to
talk about some higher
levels of the brainstem.
And especially some
pathways that are
called descending systems
and brainstem reflexes.
So we'll define what
those two things are.
We'll talk especially about
one descending system, which
is a brainstem reflex called
the olivocochlear neurons.
Their anatomy, their functions,
and their reflex pathway.
And let me just stop and tie in
once again with hearing loss.
These two brainstem
reflexes that I'm
going to talk about
clearly protect the ear
from damage due to
high-level sound.
So that is certainly one of the
functions of the Olivocochlear
neurons.
And we'll see how
that takes place.
The second brain stem
reflex that we'll talk about
is the middle ear muscle reflex.
There are two muscles
in your middle ear.
When they contract, they
make your sense of hearing
less sensitive.
Why would you ever
want that to happen?
Well again, these
muscles contract
when you're in a high-level
sound environment,
like at the NFL game.
And one of their
functions is to reduce
the sound getting
into your inner ear.
So to prevent damage from
the high-level sound that
might otherwise damage
your hair cells.
So that's the subject
of today's talk.
Now, what do I mean by reflexes
and descending systems?
Well, this is a nice diagram
from Michael Slama, who
shows in the solid lines
the pathways going up,
which we've been talking about.
And sometimes those pathways
are called ascending systems
because they go up.
So it says here in
red, the solid lines
are ascending pathways.
So by ascending, we mean from
a lower level up to a higher.
And ultimately, to the highest
level in the neural pathway
to the cortex.
There are analogous
descending systems,
which are shown here
in dashed lines.
And I think you can
see some of them.
For example, here's
auditory cortex.
And there's some
dashed lines, which
means cell bodies sitting
an auditory cortex that
project their axons down and end
at the next lowest level, which
is the auditory thalamus
or the medial geniculate.
And so that would be an
example of a descending system
because the information is
starting at the higher level
and going down to a lower level.
And at every junction
between nuclei
you can find descending systems.
And in the auditory pathway,
even at the lowest level,
you have a descending
system that
starts here in
the superior olive
and goes all the way
out to the cochlea.
And we talked about some
efferent nerve endings
on the hair cells
and the nerve fibers.
And that descending system is
called the olivocochlear system
of neurons because it
starts out in the olive
and goes to the cochlear.
OK, so that's what
descending systems
is, starting from higher levels
and going down to lower levels.
Now, how does that work out
with brainstem reflexes?
Well, we've said that
one of the functions
of these olivocochlear
neurons would
be they prevent the
cochlea from being
damaged by high-level sounds.
Well, when would you
activate that system?
Well, obviously, when
you hear a loud sound.
So the ascending pathway
has to come into the brain,
synapse in the cochlear nucleus,
go up to the olivary complex,
and then come back down to the
cochlear to prevent the damage.
And so that little loop
that I just diagrammed
could be called
a reflex pathway.
So let's define
what a reflex is.
What is a reflex?
Anybody know?
What does it mean
to act reflexively?
AUDIENCE: Automatic reaction.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So an automatic response.
And certainly, these
olivocochlear neurons
turn on automatically.
And sort of in between the
lines of that definition
means that the reflex pathway
is operating down here
in the automatic portion
of your auditory pathway
in the brainstem.
The part where you think
the auditory cortex
or the other regions of cortex
doesn't have to get involved.
You don't have to say, OK,
I'm in a loud environment.
Should I respond
with this reflex?
OK.
Yeah, maybe I will.
OK, respond.
You don't have to
think about it.
It's automatic
because it happens
in the parts of the brain where
things happen automatically.
What other things
happen in the brainstem?
Well, control of breathing.
You have the motor neurons
that come to your chest muscles
and your diaphragm that
enable you to breathe.
Those motor neurons are
located in the brainstem.
And the control of respiration
is this brainstem function.
It doesn't have to go
all the way to the cortex
and have to think about it.
Now, that's not to say that
reflexes, like the breathing
reflex, you can
say, OK, I'm going
to stop breathing for a minute.
OK, I'm going to hold my breath.
So you can, via
your higher centers,
say I'm going to send
information down here.
Maybe some of these
other descending pathways
come down to the
olivocochlear neurons and say,
I'm not going to do this
reflex for a moment.
Of course, you eventually
have to start breathing again.
But you can have higher center
control of these reflexes.
It's not that the higher
centers aren't involved.
OK, so another reflex would be
your patellar tendon reflex.
The physician tests when you
go to your doctor's office.
They hit your patellar
tendon with a little mallet
and see that your leg contracts.
And apparently, everyone
passes that test, right?
You can't walk into
the doctor's office
without having some
kind of reflex.
But they're actually testing
for hyper-reflex in that case.
And so some of these
reflexes can be in overdrive.
And that's what the
physician is testing for.
OK, so we are really
interested in what all
these descending systems do.
What do the descending
systems do in general?
Well, it actually ends up being
a very hard issue to study.
We know that those systems are
there, but what good are they?
What do they do in
our sense of hearing?
So the classic, old-fashioned
way of studying such a system
would be to go in
and make a lesion
and see how the animal's
behavior, the person's behavior
changes, or do
some kind of test.
But it turns out most of
these descending systems
are intertwined with their
corresponding ascending
pathway.
So it's very difficult to go
in and make a cut or a burning
lesion that just lesions one
of the descending pathways
and not affect the
ascending pathway, which
would complicate
the interpretation.
The reason that some of
these systems-- for example,
the olivocochlear
neurons-- are amenable
and we know a lot
about them-- are
amenable to experimentation--
is we can selectively
lesion and stimulate
them in isolation
from the ascending systems.
And let me show you a diagram
done of the olivocochlear
system that illustrates that.
So these are the olivocochlear
neurons, these stars here.
There are two types.
The red are the so-called
medial olivocochlear neurons
because they're sitting
in the medial part
of the superior olive.
The green ones are so-called
lateral olivocochlear neurons
because they're sitting
in the more lateral part
the superior olive.
And this diagram shows the cell
bodies of those olivocochlear
neurons that are innovating
this cochlea-- sending axons out
to this cochlea
on the right side.
And that defines this cochlea
as the ipsilateral cochlea.
Ipsi means the same.
So that cochlea gets a name.
That's the ipsilateral cochlear.
And you can see that these
green lateral olivocochlear
neurons are basically on
the same side of the brain
stem as the cochlea
that they innervate.
But these medial
olivocochlear neurons
are distributed on both
sides of the brain.
So there's a little bit
difference in anatomy.
Now, these are a
little bit like neurons
that we call motor neurons.
Everybody knows what a
motor neuron is, right?
It's going from the brain of the
spinal cord out to the muscle.
That's why it's
called a motor neuron.
And when it fires off,
it contracts the muscle
that it's innervating.
It turns out all the muscles
on the side of the body,
let's say the
ipsilateral muscles,
the motor neurons are located
on that same side of the brain.
So right-side muscles are always
innervated by right-side motor
neurons.
So this anatomy is a little
bit different than the anatomy
of motor neurons.
Even though these
neurons are having
an effect in the
cochlea, they're
not innervating muscles.
They're innervating
hair cells in this case.
They do use the same
neurotransmitter as muscles.
So the olivocochlear neurons
use the neurotransmitter
acetylcholine.
And so they would be
called cholinergic.
OK, so they synthesize
the acetylcholine
and their cell bodies
are transported down
to the axons and
the nerve terminals.
Out in the cochlea
use acetylcholine.
They release it.
Now, where do they
release it to?
They release it
to their targets.
And out in the periphery, these
Medial Olivocochlear Neurons,
or the MOC neurons, target
the outer hair cells.
And they release
acetylcholine directly
onto the outer hair
cells via their synapses.
The lateral
olivocochlear neurons
come out to the periphery and
they release the acetylcholine
in their synapses on
the auditory nerve fiber
peripheral dendrites.
OK, so the innervation
is very distinct.
What are the auditory
nerve peripheral dendrites?
Well, those are the ones
we've been talking about.
We've been talking about
auditory nerve fibers.
They start at the inner hair
cells for the most part.
They send messages.
That's what this
arrow is indicating.
Send messages into the brain.
When there's a sound,
the membranes move.
The outer hair cells
are electromotile.
The inner hair cells respond.
They send messages,
synaptic messages,
to their nerve fibers.
The nerve fibers spike and they
send information to the brain
through the cochlear nucleus.
These efferent fibers
are sending messages
the opposite way.
They're starting in the brain
and going out to the cochlea.
And out in the
cochlea, this arrow
means that the information
is coming from the brain
out to the outer hair cells or
the auditory nerve dendrites
here.
Is everybody clear about that?
Now, the anatomy
works out so that you
can do some pretty
interesting things.
You can make a cut of this nerve
bundle, the olivocochlear nerve
bundle.
You can stimulate it.
And right there underneath
where the word "brainstem" is,
there's a great
place to make a cut
or to electrically stimulate
and activate this system.
Well, why don't we use sound
to stimulate the system?
Well, it's a little messier.
It's cleaner to
activate this bundle
with electrical
stimulation because you
can put your stimulating
electron right on it
and only activate that system.
So that's one big advantage.
You can selectively activate
these olivocochlear neurons
and then study, well,
what the heck do
they do out in the cochlea?
What changes do they have
when you activate them?
And what changes happen
when you deactivate them
and making a cut in the system?
And de-efferent, if
you will, the cochlea.
And as this list shows, there
are a number of functions.
And if I had to pick one of
these, each of these functions
has some experimental support.
And I don't think I
would be able to pick
which is the most important.
Well, sure, if you're
at an NFL game,
you are probably experiencing
a very high sound level.
And so it becomes
important in that situation
to protect the
cochlea from damage.
So it depends on the situation.
But we're going to
go through these.
In turn, I think that
since I mentioned damage,
and since I don't
have a slide on it,
let me say how that
experimental evidence arises.
It's a very simple
type of experiment.
You take an animal.
You put it in a high-level
sound environment
comparable to an
NFL game, 120 dB.
Take the animal out,
you study its cochleas.
You can count the hair cells.
You can measure the responses.
The hearing has become
much less sensitive.
Some of the hair cells
have been killed.
OK, no big deal.
We went over that last time.
Take a second animal.
And in that animal, cut this
olivocochlear bundle going out
to, let's say, the
ipsilateral cochlea.
The olivocochlear neurons
going to this other side,
the contralateral cochlea,
leave that intact.
OK, beautiful experiment
because within just one animal,
you have one side's cochlea
has been de-efferented.
You have cut off
these efferent fibers.
The other side has a
normal innervation.
Expose the animal to 120 dB SPL.
Do the same response metrics.
Test the responses
of the cochlea.
Look at how many hair
cells have been killed.
You find that there is a huge
difference in the two ears.
Where the efference or
these olivocochlear neurons
have been cut, there's
a lot of damage
and a lot of loss
of sensitivity.
On the intact side,
it has been protected.
There is less damage
and better responses.
It's more sensitive.
So it's a very, very nice,
very elegant experiment
that's been done many times.
In probably both
of these systems,
the medials and the laterals
provide such protection
from damage.
So we can say one
of the functions
then is then protection.
What do I mean by these
other functions-- shift
the dynamic range
of hearing, reduce
the effects of noise masking,
and reduce hearing sensitivity
when paying attention
to visual tasks?
OK, we're going to go
over those one by one.
For the first one, the
experiment runs like this.
You record from these afferent
auditory nerve fibers.
And instead of cutting
these olivocochlear neurons,
you stimulate them.
You can put a stimulating
electrode right down there,
right below the
word "brainstem,"
and activate this bundle.
What happens to the
responses of the nerve fibers
when you activate this
olivocochlear system?
And that's what's shown here.
And this experiment has
been done since the 1970s.
This is an old experiment.
This is the response
in terms of the firing
rate from the auditory nerve.
And in this case, a tone is on.
So you're really driving
the auditory nerve fiber.
So the firing rate is high.
Then, during the
second black bar
here, you stimulate the
olivocochlear neurons
that are going out
to the cochlea.
And look what happens
to the firing rate.
It goes almost down to zero.
When you turn that
stimulation off,
the firing rate comes back
to about what it was before.
There's been a huge
inhibition of firing rate
in the auditory nerve.
If you plot the firing rate as
a function of the tone burst
level-- so now we're going
to do different tones
at different levels.
At low tone levels where the
fiber is firing spontaneously,
there's hardly any effect.
In mid-levels, like we
saw illustrated here,
this is without stimulation.
This is with stimulation.
There's a huge decrease
in firing rate.
And up at the
highest levels where
the fiber has become
saturated-- saturation means
that even though you're
increasing the tone burst,
you're not increasing the fire
rate coming from the fiber--
there's very little effect
of this stimulation.
How can that help us?
We have a dynamic range
problem in hearing.
Most auditory nerve fibers--
forget about the stimulation
right now.
Look at the solid curve.
The dynamic range of most
auditory nerve fibers
has just 20 or 30 dB
before saturating.
That means the fiber
goes up and it saturates.
What happens when we
get to the NFL game
or in the better case,
what happens when
we're in a restaurant
or a bar and we want
to listen to the speaker
across the table from us?
Well, that's a pretty
high sound level, 80 dB.
It's not damaging,
but it's high enough
to saturate our
auditory nerve fibers.
That means when the
added sound level
of the person across the
table from you, their voice,
adds to the
background, they're not
going to change the firing rate
of your auditory nerve fibers.
And the brain won't
know except by seeing
the person's lips move
that there is speech.
It's much better to
understand any kind of signals
to be within this rising
function of the firing rate
curve, not in the
saturated function where
there's no change
in firing rate.
OK, so how can the
olivocochlear system
help us with this
dynamic range problem?
Well, I've been emphasizing
the decrease of firing rates.
But as you can see from
this curve with stimulation
of the OC neurons, the effect
is to shift this function over.
In this case, it's
about a 20 dB shift.
And now, at 70 dB, you're in the
dynamic range of the function.
And you're not saturated
anymore as you were before.
So one of the
functions, we think then
from this type of experiment,
is the MOC efference kick in,
reflexively kick in when
you're in a high-level sound
environment.
And they shift the firing
rate functions over
so you can now
understand a speaker's
voice in a high-level
background.
Now, there are
some other factors
that change an increase of
dynamic range of hearing, which
I don't think are
important to the course.
But we have talked about
two-tone suppression.
This certainly does
the same kind of thing.
We're going to talk about
contraction of the middle ear
muscles, which also helps you
with the dynamic range problem.
So this is clearly then,
one important function
of the olivocochlear neurons.
That is, shifting dynamic range.
Now, is there
experimental evidence
besides what you
see here looking
at firing rates of
auditory nerve fibers
to suggest that the
olivocochlear system really
does this?
There is a little bit.
That is, with animals
trained to detect changes
in tones in a
background of noise,
they do it a little
bit better when
they have an intact
olivocochlear system.
You can't do these
experiments in humans
because it's very difficult
to turn this system off.
We don't know a way of turning
it off or interrupting it.
And people probably call this
system into play reflexively.
So it's difficult to do these
kinds of experiments in humans.
Now, there's another
important function
of the olivocochlear
system, which is probably
to reduce the effects
of noise masking.
And we haven't talked too much
about masking in this course.
I mean, two-tone suppression
is a kind of masking.
Masking is where you're
listening to one sound
and a second sound comes in
and interferes your ability
to detect that very first sound.
So I have a
demonstration, though,
that I think will convince you
that masking is very important.
And it runs like this.
So the demonstration
is going to be
you're listening to tone bursts,
which are the pink things here.
And they're at 2,000 Hertz,
so it's going to be kind
of a little bit above
our 1,000 standard
middle-of-the-hearing-range
frequency.
And it's going to give
you 10 tone bursts
and they're each going
to be successively softer
in sound level.
And you're supposed to count
how many steps you can hear.
And I think there
are 10 of them.
We should be able to hear
all 10 with the way I
have set the level.
The second part
of the demo is now
the signal is masked
with broadband noise.
So the broadband noise
will come on first.
Shh.
And these tone pips will
be on top of that noise.
And you're supposed to
count now how many tone
pips you can hear with
the broadband noise.
And I think there's a
little verbiage before this.
Just ignore that.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
-Critical bands by masking.
You will hear a 2,000
Hertz tone in 10 decreasing
steps of 5 decibels.
Count how many
steps you can hear.
Series are presented twice.
[BEEPING]
[END AUDIO PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: OK, so could
everybody hear most of them?
10?
All 10?
OK.
Here's the masked.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
-Now the signal is masked
with broadband noise.
[BEEPING]
[END AUDIO PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: OK, how many now?
AUDIENCE: Five.
PROFESSOR: Five?
I mean, this is not a
bad illustration, right?
When the pink tone bursts
get within the black noise,
they're pretty
much disappearing.
So clearly the noise
was an effective masker
of the tone pip.
Now, we had the example
earlier of the phenomenon
called two-tone suppression.
And that was measured in
an auditory nerve fiber.
And everybody should be able
to draw an auditory nerve
fiber tuning curve.
On the x-axis, we
have the frequency
of the sound in kilohertz.
And the y-axis, we have
the sound pressure level
for a response.
An auditory nerve tuning curves,
at least those with high CFs,
look like this.
And the characteristic frequency
is the frequency right here.
In two-tone suppression,
what we had is two tones.
The first tone is
a probe tone, which
is placed inside the nerve
fibers response area.
And if you look at a
graph of firing rate--
so this is firing-- and
you turn that tone on,
the firing rate is
going to go way up.
Maybe 100 spikes per
second because it's
within the response area.
Now, the second tone, sometimes
called the suppressor,
is put outside the response
area but close to it.
OK, so here's the probe.
This is the probe
tone, high firing rate.
And now a little
bit later, we're
going to turn on a second tone.
And this is called
the suppressor.
And I haven't drawn
this very well,
but when the suppressor
goes on, the firing rate
can come back down.
This goes off first.
And come back up.
OK.
So clearly, at least in the
discharges of auditory nerve
fibers, you can have suppressors
outside the response areas
that decrease the
response to probes.
This probe tone is going to
be signaled by auditory nerve
fibers close to that frequency.
So many auditory nerve fibers
have CFs close to 2 kilohertz.
This noise has energy
throughout the frequency range,
if it's absolutely white noise.
Some of its noise will be
within the response area,
but some of it will be
in suppression areas.
And these suppression
areas can be
either side of the
excitatory area.
And they can be big.
And in some cases, they can
overrule the excitation,
or at least decrease it.
So some of the reason you
couldn't hear the tone when
it was masked by
the noise is because
of two-tone suppression.
This is sometimes called
suppressive masking.
There's another kind of masking
that's important-- it may
be equally important-- and
it's called adaptive masking.
And it comes from the
process called adaptation.
Almost all sensory
systems have adaptation,
which means that when
you turn a stimulus on,
you get a vigorous response.
And even though the stimulus
stays on, after a while
the response dies
down a little bit.
And that process is
called adaptation.
So I've illustrated the
process of adaptation
for auditory nerve fibers
in this next graph.
Here's that pink
tone burst at 2,000
Hertz we were listening to.
There's the auditory
nerve response to it.
Right as the tone
burst goes on, there's
going to be a vigorous
discharge, which
die eyes down and
becomes a smaller-- still
a discharge, but a
smaller discharge.
And that process is
called adaptation.
Where do you think
that process arises?
OK, while you're
thinking about that,
I'm going to draw a picture
of what's happening here.
So you have the three
rows of outer hair cells.
We have the inner hair cell.
We have the auditory
nerve fiber.
And we're recording here.
And we're saying,
we turn the sound on
and you get a whole
bunch of spikes
from that single
auditory nerve fiber.
But after a few milliseconds
or so, the response dies down.
What experiment could you do?
We don't know where
that process is arising.
We can't explain it.
What experiment would you do
to study where that comes from?
Anybody?
Here's the tone.
Here's the response
from the nerve fiber.
What do we need to
figure out where
that adaptation is taking place?
Well, how about recording
from somewhere else?
What about recording
from the hair cell?
OK, if you do that, the hair
cell doesn't fire spikes,
but it has a receptor potential
in response to the sound.
The receptor goes
on and stays on.
OK, where is adaptation
taking place?
Well, somewhere between the
hair cell and the nerve fiber.
The hair cell doesn't adapt,
the nerve fiber does adapt.
what could explain
adaptation then given that?
Anybody?
OK, what do we have here?
We have a synaptic ribbon with
lots of synaptic vesicles.
The tone goes on.
You have a whole bunch
of synaptic vesicles.
You release them because the
hair cell has depolarized.
You have a burst of
auditory nerve firing.
And you can make new
synaptic vesicles, right?
Yeah, but it takes time.
OK, so as time goes on,
you've released all of these
or many of them.
And you can make some new ones,
but maybe not quite as fast
as you've released them.
So you deplete your
synaptic vesicles.
The hair cell's
still responding.
There are fewer vesicles and
fewer neurotransmitter released
to the nerve and so the
nerve firing dies out.
So adaptation is often ascribed
to the diminished release
of neurotransmitter.
And so far, that's all
adaptation to a single tone.
How does that explain masking?
Well, if your nerve fiber
responded to the noise--
at the very beginning you
heard that noise come on-- shh.
And then the tone came
on a little bit later.
If the tone is high
in level, sure, it's
going to still have some
synaptic vesicles to release.
But if the tone is very
soft, the hair cell
is not going to be able to
release synaptic vesicles
because they've
already been released
at the beginning of the noise.
So adaptive masking is where
you have, to a certain extent,
run out of hair cell
neurotransmitter.
And there's none, or much
less, left to release.
Clearly, adaptive masking
means that this fiber is also
responding to the mask or
the noise in this case.
So in adaptive masking
you have to have
a stimulus that excites.
The masker has to excite the
nerve fiber and the hair cell.
And the probe-- probe
is always exciting it.
So that is a second
explanation for masking.
Now in this case, the
olivocochlear system
can actually help you
with adaptive masking.
How can it help you?
Well, in this
case, if you also--
when you start to
hear this noise,
you call that olivocochlear
system into play.
And it acts.
What does it act to do?
It decreases the firing
of the auditory nerve.
Then when you have
the tone come along,
you have plenty of
neurotransmitter
left in the hair cell because
you haven't released it all.
And you have at least
some to be released
in response to the tone.
So in this case,
the third function
then of the
olivocochlear system is
to reduce the
effects of masking.
And we should have
said back here
when I listed the functions,
reduce the effects of noise
masking, especially
adaptive noise masking.
The kind where the masker
excites the fiber unlike
suppressive masking where the
masker reduces the response.
There are certainly important
and reliable studies
where animals in which the
olivocochlear bundle has
been cut have much more of a
problem with noise masking.
They cannot detect signals that
are buried in a noise masker
as well as animals with an
intact olivocochlear bundle.
So clearly, that is
a viable function.
Now finally, and this is pretty
important for our course here,
there's been this fourth idea
of what the olivocochlear
reflex could do.
And it's always been a
little bit wishy-washy
because there hasn't been really
good experimental evidence.
Until this paper-- this
paper Delano et al,
2007-- is the paper that we
have listed for reading today.
And this paper clearly
shows that another function
of the olivocochlear system is
when you're paying attention
to something that
is not auditory,
like a visual stimulus,
the olivocochlear system
acts and reduces your
sense of hearing.
You're not using hearing
for whatever task,
so you desensitize your
hearing and you pay attention
to the visual system.
OK, so how is this
going to work?
So this paper
trained chinchillas
as the experimental animal.
And the task was to pay
attention to lights.
So let me get my
pointer here so I
can point out a little better.
So this is the task
in part A here.
And this neutral cue is a
light that's straight ahead
from the experimental animal.
And that goes on and
says to the animal
that the trial is starting.
Then, that goes off and
one of two targets appears.
Either a left target
or a right target.
And these are little spots
of light to the animal's left
or to the right.
The task then is if the
left target went on,
the animal goes and
presses the left lever.
And if it does that correctly,
it gets a food reward.
If the light went
on on the right,
the right target
was illuminated,
the right lever is
supposed to be pressed.
And if the animal
does that correctly,
then it gets a food reward.
If it does nothing or if
it presses the wrong lever,
it's punished by a timeout.
And the animals
are food deprived,
so they're motivated
to do this task.
That's the visual task.
Now, on top of that there's
some auditory stimuli presented.
And they're not
relevant to the task.
They're just ongoing
all the time.
And here then in B are the
target and the neutral cue
lights and the response period.
And the auditory stimulus
going on all the time
is a click or a tone burst.
And it's just going
on all the time.
And they're making
some recordings
from the auditory system.
And in this case, they're
making a recording
from the round window
of the cochlea.
And if you had a microscope,
you could see some little blips
right here in response
to the clicks.
And they're pretty big here.
But as time goes on,
they get smaller.
And that's plotted right here.
The response they're
measuring is called the CAP,
and that's the Compound
Action Potential.
And if you are astute
here, the action potential
is another word for
"spikes" or "impulses."
But they're not measuring
from one single fiber,
they're putting a big
electrode on the round window
of the cochlear and they're
measuring the summed
or compound action potential
from the whole auditory nerve.
It's just a convenient
place to do it.
You can do it in
an awake animal.
You can do it in awake behaving
animal like we have here.
When you turn on a click, almost
all the auditory nerve fibers
fire synchronously and
you get a big response.
Hardly have to do
any averaging at all.
OK, so that's the response,
the compound action potential.
And this graph plots the CAP
amplitude-- how big it is.
Upward on the graph
is a big amplitude
and lower is a
diminished amplitude.
And right here at
zero-- they just
call it zero because
that's sort of the baseline
before the trial even starts.
So in this first bar here
is the neutral OK cue.
That's the thing in the middle
that says to the animal,
the task is starting.
And right away during
that neutral cue,
these black dots show you that
the compound action potential
is decreasing.
Then, the neutral cue goes
off and the target-- one
of the targets goes on.
Either the left or right.
And the compound action
potential further decreases.
Then, the animal makes
its response here
in this dashed line.
OK, gets its food reward
and the CAP comes back up.
OK, now how do we explain this?
Well, the CAP is the
summed firing rate
of many auditory nerve fibers.
Instead of stimulation
of the OC neurons
decreasing the firing rate,
essentially the animal
itself has turned
on its OC neurons
and the firing
rate has gone down.
Or the summed response, in
this case, has gone down.
The animal has said to
the olivocochlear system,
I'm starting a visual task.
I don't want to pay attention to
extraneous things, like sounds.
So I'm going to
decrease my sensitivity
in hearing by activating
these olivocochlear neurons.
Now, pay attention to
the important targets,
which are visual.
Now, there are some other
symbols in here that are open.
They're a little
bit harder to see.
But there are some
CAP amplitudes
from another trial of
these same animals.
And for one reason or
another, the chinchillas
didn't always do the task.
Every now and then they would
just not pay attention to it.
They wouldn't press the lever.
They wouldn't respond at all.
As if they were
sort of spaced out,
thinking about something
else if you will.
And in those cases,
which are timeout trials.
Let's see, what
did they call them?
Ah, omissions.
This little symbol
right here is omissions.
So it's an omission trial
where the animal didn't even
do the task.
In that case, the
olivocochlear system
is apparently not
called into play at all.
The animal is just
not doing the task.
Now, the investigators were
very astute and they said,
we're going to make
the task a little more
difficult for the
animals and see
if we get a bigger effect here.
And the way to make
the task difficult
is make the targets brief.
So instead of the target going
on for a couple of seconds,
the target went on for
just a half a second.
And here's a trial with
And there was a big decrease
in the auditory response.
If the target went
on for a long time,
there was less of a decrease.
And this is the effect plotted
as a function of target
duration.
Brief targets made
this job harder
to do for the chinchillas.
So this is clearly,
at least to me,
some evidence that you call into
play the olivocochlear system
when you're doing a visual task.
So maybe as humans, we do this
when we're trying to read.
We're concentrating on
the book, visual stimulus.
And our neighbors
music is going on.
It's not relevant
to what we're doing.
Maybe we're listening
to it subconsciously,
but we decrease the response
to that auditory stimulus
because it's not
important to the task.
So clearly then,
this is good evidence
from this single study
for the last function
for the olivocochlear
system, which
is that you reduce your hearing
sensitivity when attending
to visual or perhaps
other modality tasks.
So these are the
four basic functions
then for the
olivocochlear system.
Now, before I leave the
olivocochlear system,
let's do a little review here
on exactly how it's acting.
So we said we're activating
these systems going out
to the hair cells
and we're reducing
the responses of the
auditory nerve fibers.
Something I haven't told you
but was observed maybe 20
years after the phenomenon
was first discovered
is the idea of which
of these systems
is being used here
when we electrically
stimulate the system
and activated it.
It turns out that the
medial olivocochlear neurons
have big, fat myelinated axons.
And you can maybe appreciate
that from this drawing
that these are very thick lines.
The lateral olivocochlear
neurons have very thin axons.
And one effect of that
besides how fast they conduct
impulses is when you stimulate,
for example, at this position
here in the brainstem, it takes
a huge amount of stimulating
current to activate
very thin nerve
fibers like the lateral
olivocochlear neurons.
If you apply a huge
stimulating current here,
the current spreads
to everywhere,
including the
facial nerve, which
causes the experimental
animal to twitch.
So that's almost never done.
More moderate levels
of stimulation current
are applied here.
And at those levels, the
predominant system activating
is the medial
olivocochlear neurons.
Those MOC neurons
send their fibers out
to the outer hair cells.
And we say when they
act on the outer hair
cells, the responses of
the nerve fibers diminish.
As we review, we should be
able to account for that.
OK, we are stimulating
nerve fibers
that go out to the
outer hair cells here.
And we're recording
the responses
from the auditory nerve
fibers right here.
Of course, these
olivocochlear neurons
are sending messages
out to the periphery.
And the auditory nerve
fibers are sending messages
into the brain.
Somebody explain to me
what's happening here.
What are we doing to the cochlea
to cause these responses to go
down when we apply
this simulation?
Anybody?
We're affecting the
outer hair cells, right?
What are the outer hair cells?
The cochlea amplifier, right?
It turns out that
releasing the acetylcholine
on to the outer
hair cells decreases
their electromotility.
So in effect, it discusses the
gain of the cochlear amplifier.
If the cochlea is
less amplified,
the inner hair cell stereocilia
are going to be bent less.
They're going to release
less neurotransmitter
to the associated
auditory nerve fibers.
And we're going to measure
less of a response.
That is how the
olivocochlear neurons--
those that go to the
outer hair cells--
affect the responses of
the auditory nerve fiber.
So this decrease
in firing rate then
is a manifestation
of turning down
the gain of the
cochlear amplifier.
It was quite a mystery when
this innervation was first
worked out before the
outer hair cells really
were known to be the amplifier.
How could stimulation of fibers
going to the outer hair cells
give you decreases in
responses of fibers
coming from the
inner hair cells?
And now that the outer
hair cells are clearly
associated with the cochlear
amplifier, it's clear.
Now, what was the
loss of sensitivity
when the outer hair cells
were completely gone
or when their prestin
was knocked out?
Anybody?
What was the loss
of sensitivity?
40 to 60 dB, right?
So if you eliminated
the cochlear amplifier,
we had a loss of 40 to 60 dB.
What kind of effect do
we have from stimulation
of the olivocochlear neurons?
Well, the length of this arrow
when brought down to the x-axis
shows you how much
sensitivity is lost.
You could overcome
this by dialing
in an increase of sound pressure
level to make up for it.
You could titrate the effect
of decreasing the gain
by increasing the
sound stimulus.
And the width of that arrow,
the length of that arrow,
is about 25 dB.
So instead of eliminating
the cochlear amplifier,
you just reduce its gain by the
action of these olivocochlear
neurons.
The effect is about 25 dB.
Which is a fairly strong effect,
but you're not completely
ridding the cochlea of
the cochlear amplifier.
You're decreasing its gain.
OK, so that's kind of a review
on outer hair cell function
and how these olivocochlear
neurons affect the outer hair
cells.
So you really have a
controllable cochlear amplifier
controlled by these
olivocochlear neurons,
or efferent neurons,
or descending neurons
coming from the brain
out to the cochlea.
Any questions about that?
OK.
If there aren't, then I'll go
on to another reflex pathway.
Maybe I actually do have one
more thing to talk about.
Right.
Let me just mention this
idea that this reflex pathway
is kind of getting teased
out by current studies.
And it can be a little
bit complicated,
so let me show you
what people are working
on now in the
olivocochlear reflex.
Here, I think I've
flipped the slide on you
so that this slide shows
the MOC neurons going
to the left cochlea.
OK.
That's the ipsilateral cochlea.
How do these MOC neurons
get their inputs?
Where do they come from?
OK.
Well, the red and blue are
the olivocochlear neurons
coming out to the cochlea and
the purple are their inputs.
And all of the inputs have to,
of course, use the cochlea.
To get this olivocochlear
neurons to fire in response
to sound, you have to
activate the cochlea.
You activate the auditory nerve.
The auditory nerve goes into
the cochlea nucleus then.
And that's where the
limits of our understanding
are sort of-- we are
approaching the limits
of our understanding.
What are the cochlear
nucleus neurons
that are the so-called MOC
reflex interneurons that
are drawn in purple here?
When we talked about
the cochlear nucleus,
we identified a bunch of
different types of neurons.
We had spherical
cells, globular cells.
Both of those are
known as bushy cells.
We had stellate cells.
We had pyramidal cells.
We had octopus cells.
Which of those provide the
inputs for the MOC neurons?
And that's assuming
a direct pathway,
which I'll give you from some
other experimental evidence
which I won't show you.
At least one group
of cochlear nucleus
neurons projects
to the MOC neurons.
And how do I know that?
Well, you can record
from the MOC neurons
and turn a sound on.
And in less than 5 milliseconds,
you can get a response.
So there isn't enough time
for the reflex pathway
to go up to the
auditory cortex, which
takes about 4 or 5 synapses.
And to go around there
and start coming down,
that takes 10 or
20 milliseconds.
You get a response
here very quickly.
And so there isn't enough time,
except for cochlear nucleus
to project directly there.
So which of those cochlear
nucleus neurons do project?
Well, we don't know
absolutely for sure.
But it looks like
from lesion studies
that probably the stellate
cells in the cochlear nucleus.
And especially
the stellate cells
in the part of the cochlear
nucleus called the PVCN.
And I think we talked
about the ventral cochlear
nucleus and the dorsal
cochlear nucleus
as being the big main divisions.
In the VCN, there's two
subdivisions, AVCN and PVCN.
And the stellate cells
that seem to be-- the MOC
reflex interneurons
are in the PVCN.
How do we know that?
You can make lesion studies in
various parts of the cochlear
nucleus.
If you lesion the DCN, this
reflex goes along fine.
If you lesion the AVCN,
it goes along fine.
In the PVCN, if you
make a lesion there,
the reflex is interrupted.
In the PVCN, there are a
number of types of neurons.
The ones that seem to have the
right characteristics in terms
of latency, sustainability
of response,
tuning, are the stellate cells.
So it's a little bit
of a squishy argument.
Stellate cells seem to
project to the right way.
So most of the evidence
is behind the idea
that those particular
cochlear nucleus
cells are the ones that are
the reflex interneurons.
Now, another point of this slide
is that the MOC reflex pathway
is consensually organize.
So what does consensual mean?
What does consensual in
terms of reflex mean?
Not in terms of
consensual sex, in terms
of reflexes or
brainstem organization.
How does the detective in the
old 1950s black and white movie
come to the victim
whose lying down
and shine a flashlight
in the eye-- how does he
decide that the
person is really dead?
The pupil constricts if the
person's still alive, right?
The brainstem is still working.
It's a very quick test.
You don't have to
have a stethoscope
and listen to the heartbeat.
You can be brain dead and
still have a heartbeat.
But if you shine light
in a person's eye,
the pupil constricts, right?
So that is a brainstem reflects.
The pupillary
constriction reflex.
It turns out if you shine
light in the right eye, what
happens to your left pupil?
It constricts, right.
So both pupils constrict from
just a stimulus in one eye.
And that is called consensual.
It means in agreement.
The left and the right side do
the same thing in agreement.
So most of these
brainstem reflexes
are consensually organized.
And it turns out
that you can look
at the MOC reflex
in your left ear.
And obviously, if you
put sound in there,
that reflex is
going to take place.
But you can also
elicit that reflex
by sound in the right ear.
For some reason, sound in either
ear can activate the reflex.
Not quite as well,
labeling studies
have shown that just
some of the MOC neurons
are responsive to sound in
the ipsilateral cochlea.
That is, the cochlea
that they project to.
And about half as many
are responsive to sound
in the other ear.
The so-called
contralateral cochlea
and the so-called
contra response,
MOC neurons in red here.
Labeling studies have
shown these contra
response neurons are sitting
on the side of the brain
as the cochlea that
they innervate.
But the ipsi
response neurons are
located on the opposite side
of the brain [INAUDIBLE].
And knowing those
response characteristics,
then you can draw
the purple pathway
that's necessary to drive them.
These contra response neurons
respond to sound over here,
so they must get
this purple arrow.
These ipsi response neurons
are responsive to sound here,
so they must get
this purple pathway.
And it's kind of complicated,
but that's the kind of studies
that people do now on
these brainstem reflexes.
And I want to just
say one more thing.
People are now working on where
the neurons go in the cochlea.
So these are some tuning
curves from these MOC neurons.
So they show sharp tuning
just like the auditory nerve.
And where do they go?
Well, they have a very nice
so-called tonotopic projection
into the cochlea.
That is, an MOC
neuron with a high CF
goes and innervates at a
very basal cochlear location.
and.
An MOC neuron with a low CF
goes and innervates closer
to the apex.
And this black line
shows the mapping
for auditory nerve fibers.
Those are the ones coming
out of the cochlea.
And the colored dots
show the mapping
for the fibers going
back on to the cochlea.
Everything, remember,
in the auditory system
is tonotopically organized.
So it's no surprise
that that would happen.
But it opens up the idea
maybe that if you're
interested in turning off
your sense of hearing just
for low frequencies, you
could activate these fibers,
go out to the cochlea
in just the apical part,
and leave the basal part.
Let's say you're very
interested in listening
to high-frequency sounds.
Leave the basal part intact.
Or vice-versa.
You could control the
cochlea in a frequency band
by frequency band manner.
The anatomical
substrate there is
laid for that type
of manipulation.
You don't have to shut down
the whole sense of hearing.
OK, so let's move on
to the second system
that I want to talk about.
That is, the brainstem reflexes
associated with the stapedius
and tenser tympani
middle-ear muscles.
These are two muscles that
are in the middle ear.
Remember the middle ear was
the part of the ear that
starts at the eardrum
and ends at the cochlea?
There are two
middle ear muscles.
There's a tensor tympani.
This is shaded in brown here.
And there's the stapedius
shaded in red here.
The stapedius tugs
on the stapes.
And the tensor tympani
tugs on the malleus.
But it gets its name
because when it contracts,
it looks like-- if you're
looking at the eardrum
through an otoscope, it looks
like the tympanic membrane gets
really tense.
It looks a little flaccid
before it contracts,
and then it gets real tense.
So it's a tensor tympani.
And what happens when
those muscles contract?
That's shown in this next slide.
They reduce the
sound transmission
through the middle ear.
This is just simply a
graph on contraction
of the stapedius muscle.
This is during the contraction.
This is the magnitude change.
So it looks like sound doesn't
get through the middle ear
anywhere near as
well as normally.
And you have about a 25 dB
decrease in sensitivity.
Simply what that means is
that usually the eardrum moves
and these bones move and they
convey efficiently the sound
into the inner ear.
But if you tug on the
muscles and contract them,
then the bones don't
vibrate as easily.
And the sound doesn't
get into the inner ear.
So this is again, like
the olivocochlear system,
an inhibitory system in
that when it's activated
it reduces your
sensitivity of hearing.
Now, how are these
muscles controlled?
Well, they're controlled by
neurons coming from the brain.
But in the case of
muscles, of course,
they're always on the
same side of the brain
as the muscles they innervate.
So the left stapedius muscle
is controlled by motor neurons
on the left side of your brain.
And the stapedius
muscle motor neurons
run in the seventh
cranial nerve.
And what's the
seventh cranial nerve?
Anybody?
We have the eighth cranial nerve
is auditory and vestibular.
What's the seventh?
Anybody?
AUDIENCE: Facial.
PROFESSOR: Facial, right.
So the stapedius axons
go in that cranial nerve.
The stapedius motor
neuron axons, should say.
And for the tensor tympani,
it's the fifth cranial nerve.
Tensor tympani.
So some very
interesting experiments
have been done in
people who have
a compromise of their
seventh cranial nerve.
Does anybody know
what Bell's palsy is?
what a palsy is?
Palsy means your motor neurons
aren't working so well.
So what happens?
In Bell's palsy, the
seventh cranial nerve
innervates facial musculature.
So if you have a problem,
a cut seventh nerve
or a Bell's palsy, which
is a viral infection
of the seventh cranial
nerve on one side, one
side of your facial features
droop because the muscles
there, which ordinary keep
your muscles in good control
of your face, they're
not working anymore.
So a person with a Bell's palsy
has a droopy face on that side.
The other side is fine because
the other seventh cranial
nerve is working just fine.
Or it usually is.
It's very often the case
that it's unilateral.
In Scandinavia where you can
do experiments on humans,
or you could at least
do experiments on humans
to a much greater extent than
in the United States, what
some enterprising
researchers did was
they took people who had
Bell's palsy and they said,
well, you can go and
work in your ordinary job
in the automobile factory
where it's really loud.
They tested their hearing
before they went to work
and they tested their hearing
at the end of the work day.
They tested it in the left
ear and in the right ear.
Let's say the right ear
was the palsied ear.
And then, left ear,
which was normal,
person came out at
the end of the workday
and their hearing
was just right.
In the palsied side,
at the end of the day
they had a temporary
threshold shift.
That means that if they're
hearing was down at 0 dB
at the beginning of the
day, their thresholds
were elevated at
the end of the day.
And hopefully, it's temporary.
That is, if you sleep all
night and things recover,
you're back to
normal the next day.
But what had happened-- this
is a beautiful experiment
because it's
controlled-- left-right
in the same individual.
So whatever that person did--
took drugs, or got infections,
or whatever-- was
hopefully bilateral.
It's a human, so you
can test very well
thresholds of hearing.
Presumably then, the
stapedius muscle,
which was not working
on the palsied side,
couldn't protect the
ear from the high levels
of sound in the
work environment.
And there was
damage-- hopefully,
temporary-- to that
person's hearing.
So clearly, the contraction
of these muscles,
which makes sound not go
through the middle ear as well,
is of beneficial effect.
For example, they protect
the cochlea from damage.
People who are at the NFL games
are having their middle ear
muscles contract.
Certainly, the stapedius.
And probably the tensor tympani.
They probably reduce the
effects of noise masking.
So that is a little
twist here in terms
of the spectrum of
where these muscles act.
It turns out when the muscles
contract, both the stapedius
and the tensor tympani,
they affect low frequencies
to a much greater
extent than highs.
For example, here you have
a reduction in transmission
through the middle ear of 25
dB at the lowest frequency
and 0, or even actually,
improved transmission
at the high frequencies.
And if you've ever been in
a car and you accelerate
to go on the highway,
you know the low rumbling
of the sound of the car means
you have to turn the radio up
when you want to enjoy your
music because the low rumbling
of the car, these
low frequencies
tend to mask the
interesting high frequencies
or mid-frequencies of
the music that you're
trying to listen
to on the radio.
So low frequencies tend to mask
mid and highs very effectively.
And so if you decrease
the transmission
for the low
frequencies, you reduce
the effects of noise masking.
Especially by
low-frequency noises.
Now finally, an
interesting thing
that is clearly known for
the middle ear muscles
is that they
contract just before
and during when you speak.
During you speak, OK?
I don't know who wrote that.
But anyway, when I speak,
I'm contracting my middle ear
muscles.
And the idea there is
perhaps when you're speaking,
you don't want to
listen to yourself.
And if you're speaking in
a loud voice, like 80 dB,
I'm trying to project here.
Or if I'm yelling at
some family members,
I want to not decrease my
sense of hearing or damage it.
So I contract my own
middle ear muscles
to prevent self-stimulation.
After I finish my
speaking or vocalization,
my muscles then stop
their contraction,
going back to normal.
And then my sense of
hearing is very acute
because it hasn't been damaged
by my own vocalization.
And later on in
the course, when we
talk about echolocation in bats.
So bats send out
this pulse of sound,
which is their vocalization.
And they listen for an echo.
The pulse of sound
can be 120 dB.
They're really screaming because
their targets, the insects
that they hunt, are
very, very small.
And there's not much
physical surface
for that to reflect off.
So the reflecting
sound is very small.
And so they maximize
that reflection
by emitting a very
high-level acoustic pulse.
And they don't want to damage
or desensitize their hearing
because they're listening
to very soft reflections
from the echoes.
So bats clearly tense their
middle ear muscles right
before they make this
echo-locating pulse.
We don't know if that's the case
for the olivocochlear neurons.
It just hasn't
been investigated.
It's very hard to measure their
effects during vocalizations.
But perhaps they do.
Certainly, the middle
ear muscles do.
OK, that's all I wanted to say
so we're sort of out of time.
Any questions?
And I want to make
one announcement
about Wednesday's class.
So in Wednesday's
class we're going
to be talking about
sound localization,
and listening to sounds that
differ in intraural timing
and level difference.
And so the usual
demonstrations that I play
aren't going to work
very well because we
want to manipulate
just one of those cues.
So we're going to be
listening in headphones.
So I have some great demos.
So please, if you can, bring
some headphones or earbuds.
And maybe download the demos
from the course website.
I have a few players that I
can also circulate around.
But if some people have
these demos on their laptops,
that would be more convenient.
OK?
See you on Wednesday.